um
this is dustin tv
um here we go hurry hey jj
can you ex okay i know you can hang up
with me it's fine i don't care but but
before you do
oh god this one yeah yeah can you
explain dustin tv for me i'm about to
play him and i kind of want a little
background
all right well here's a little
background he likes wearing skirts uh he
lives in a trailer
and he has uh three alabama championship
rings
uh four championship belts
and did i say you wear skirts yes you
did okay
he wears skirts nice okay i'm excited
actually
all right all right let's check it out
i'm gonna play his video real quick here
uh and i'll be right back hey fellow
youtubers
welcome to the dustin tv i just got my
headset in the mail today you know it's
kind of crazy
that i checked see
when i order stuff i always track it
and it says it was still in transit
but that was kind of weird but anyways
let's get doing the unboxing here
yep i knew it was going to be the
headset itself
wow look at that
the hell is it this is what the box it
comes in
i got the blue and black one because i
got the ps4
and the reason why i got some new
headsets because
i will be getting the ps5 in september
if he gets a ps5 before i do
i am going to be so angry
um you might i think he already has it
how the [ __ ] did
dustin tv get a ps5 before i did
well you know sometimes you got to be
nice to the tards
and you gotta you know let them have
their thing but he's
his sister took all his skirts and he's
actually happier
i'm sorry i'm sorry can you please
repeat that sentence again
his sister all of his skirts
and his championship rings and his
championship belts
why because he wasted all of his stimi
money on skirts and championship rings
what is he dating hypernova he's worse
than dating hypernova
but the only good thing is this one
lives on its own so they've
literally done what they should have
done with dayton and just got him his
own place and paid for it so you can
[ __ ] with them
okay so let's i gotta see a little bit
more of this guy this guy's my favorite
let's get on with the box unboxing
oh yeah yeah good point afro you haven't
seen the uh the crocs yet
he has a crop collection i want to do i
want to start doing them i'm just gonna
start doing unboxing
i mean videos it's a lucrative youtube
video there's some people that make a
lot of money doing this
yeah oh another shot
yeah i mean people are saying that he's
bad but he's definitely not as bad as
dayton
um not as bad as dayton but there
this is an onion once you peel a couple
of uh layers back you'll
start seeing it okay
i mean wow look at this hey royce
i spy something blue okay what was that
you know i spy something blue yes okay
now i'm gonna i'm gonna point this out
here i know this is gonna sound silly
you know i have this same headset
that he's on box i have the same one the
identical one
and it's actually not bad
i mean look headsets are headsets man i
got the a10s because it was cheap and
i just grabbed him but again i spy
something blue
but what am i looking at the dusting
show does
we like to play uh i spy with his
background
is it the pepsi on the ground is it
no this is the skirt royce well i know
the skirt is black
obviously the skirt
i thought there was something something
brown probably his [ __ ] underwear
you're right but it was the deer okay it
was the deer it was the deer
all right let's let's play another video
from this guy um
royce yeah eight five say that again
[ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it
okay whatever anyway let's continue with
this dusting what a dick
um he was waiting for it
so i this one i actually did see all the
way through and you want to talk about
reaction videos
wait till you see his reaction video the
godzilla movie
we're playing the whole thing because
it's worth it
[Music]
that in some ways
that's godzilla you don't shoot godzilla
let's go
[Music]
they're fighting they're fighting
they're fighting
the [ __ ] out of him
that we're not seeing here
and they're the last one standing
here we go
hey buddy i just i sent you another one
uh
and and and do me a favor uh pull up zz
top she's got legs
i will okay i got it and so
by the way nine to five thanks i just
wanted to put thank you jj i just wanted
to point out that
that was his entire reaction was
oh that was his entire reaction was
that was that was the whole reaction
video i wish there was more
but that was his reaction okay so jj
says i gotta play this one
hey fully okay and he says i gotta pull
look i haven't seen this one so this is
i'm gonna just trust him on this one
she's got legs let's see
he's got legs i'll pick a pull up a
cover that way don't get in trouble
here we go
[Music]
hello youtubers welcome to the dustin
tv i'm fixing to show you
how to walk in a red
shiny leather skirt
every day
[Music]
so
[Music]
look at him crocs look at him crocs
i mean look if if you got them
flaunt them if you got if you got the
legs you flaunt them so
this is now we get to what i wanted to
do here
and we must do this because this is only
going to make things better
it's only going to make things better
here we go
hey fellow youtubers welcome to the
dustin tv
i just wanted to make this little short
little video
uh this video is going to be called
uh road to a thousand
subscribers right now right now
right now he's at 885.
885. okay i'm up to
854
but guys that's my goal getting up to a
thousand
because it took me a long time
to try to get up to a thousand let's do
it
let's do it to get up to where i'm at
now
dustin tv let's do it there's the lake
come on we can do this but
i do appreciate everybody
as everybody is helping me
to watch my youtube channel and enjoy it
and liking it and subscribing
to my channel and a lot of people are
like oh this is going to [ __ ] up my
youtube feed
just do what i do do what everybody does
you need a burner account you need a
burner account just to subscribe to
stuff like this
you make a youtube burner account and
just to show you i'm going to subscribe
on my main account boom subscribed
make a burner account just for
subscribing channel
i appreciate it if it wasn't
for y'all i wouldn't have
854 subscribers yes
i'm going to um
what i'm saying is guys i'm
i'm going to road to up to a thousand
subscribers
we're gonna get you there buddy that's
my main goal
if you know somebody who's not
sub to me just share my
i know 351 people on youtube right now
and uh 22 on trovo
and 27 on d lab that aren't subscribed
to you right now and i think you guys
should be subscribing because
if everybody watching right now
subscribes he hits a thousand by the end
of the show
videos and try to help me out
to get to it steve says dude i'm so
confused making a channel we need to
shout offline a g buddy can you help a g
could help you with this aj can you help
steve out i mean i'll still talk to you
after the show obviously steve but
can you help me make a channel
and i would do i would appreciate it
and i've been trying to go so steve by
the way if this guy can make a channel
that we're watching now
i have a lot of faith in you
live streams and show love
and subscribe to their channels
and liking their videos and live stream
and stuff
that's what i've been doing here last
couple days
but it's at 9 41.
to get to 9 42. subscribers
and i do appreciate it and thank you
so much for getting me
to 943. 854
subscribers i know it took me
a while to get up to that
but i am so thankful i have y'all as a
friend
and y'all are helping me and i do
appreciate it
and i hope god
bless every one of y'all and i hope
y'all had a i'm trying to understand
this so he's a slow redneck who wears
skirts and crocs
did i sum that up did i sum that up
correctly
yeah tell him day wave sent you a
wonderful
year in 2021
and guys y'all be safe out there because
we're still
in this pandemic with the comet with the
cove okay
thank you for showing me love and i'll
see y'all on the next one guys
i love y'all he is
just just just the best he's just the
best
um let me see here let's uh
oh grilling is deer sausage here we go
hey
fellow youtubers welcome to the dustin
tv be right back
i'm gonna show you my
my uh starter
my uh
charcoal starter
and stuff this is
what is it is you can see my grill
i'm fixing to cook some steak and some
deer sausage
and yeah i am wearing a
skirt
it's going pretty good it's actually uh
let's see it's already start to
heat up now
look at all that smoke
and there's the two kitty cats
and yeah i'm wearing a
jacket with a knee length
skirt on
you know where does he live with skirts
where does he live this [ __ ] is about to
be flamed up
looks like it
yeah my cats are
i'll probably buy two two bags was that
a nazi flat i don't know i gotta look
let's see oh wait a second hold on um
no that's gonna show you my
it's not a nazi flag
jj is he gay
wait i don't no that's a georgia flag
do
it looks more flammable which he means
flammable
on the phone it does it does
it actually
let's see if we get a bit of look at
that flag
it's right quick
[Music]
okay there we go
look i want mr dex royce are you
interested in him
it's not what you think only sexually
uh let's see where dustin tv is at right
now let's check it out
950 come on guys 50 more we get them up
there dustin tv let's do this
let's do this we're so close
we're so close and i believe in
everybody